that are tensored to cat zero. So we get one 12th plus one quarter, which is one third and
conditioned on the outcome zero.
The probabilistic state of Y
becomes this vector normalized or equivalently divided by the probability
that we just calculated, and so what we get is
this vector right here.
The second possibility is that the measurement outcome is one and the calculation is
done in a similar way using the second term in the expression
rather than the first term. And if you'd like to verify the details, go ahead as always and pause the video to give yourself a moment do that.
You can perform the same
sorts of calculations to figure out what happens when
Y is measured rather than X.
It's the same method up to a symmetry between the two systems.
This time we write the
probability vector like this, isolating the standard basis vectors on the right like you see right here,
but otherwise it works
in exactly the same way.
You can also use this method
for more than two systems.
It can get a little bit
messy just to write down all of the required expressions, but conceptually it's
exactly the same idea.
Finally, for the portion of the lesson
on classical information, we'll take a look at operations
on probabilistic states
of multiple systems. Following the same reasoning that we've now seen a couple of times.
We conclude that probabilistic operations on multiple systems are just
like probabilistic operations on single systems represented
by stochastic matrices.
But this time those matrices
have rows and columns that correspond to the Cartesian product of the individual system's,
classical state sets.
That is we're simply
viewing a compound system as if it's a single system and falling back on the description for how probabilistic operations work
for single systems from
the previous lesson.
Here's an example of an operation called a controlled-NOT
operation on two bits X and Y.
This is in fact a deterministic operation and the way that it works is
that if X is equal to one, then a NOT operation is performed on Y
and otherwise if X is equal
to zero then nothing happens.
The bit X is sometimes
called a control bit because it determines whether
or not the NOT operation is applied to Y
and Y is called the target bit because it's the bit that gets acted upon by the NOT operation.
You can also imagine
swapping the roles of X and Y so that Y becomes the control
bit and X becomes the target, but that's a different operation
from the one that's described here because the operation isn't
symmetric between X and Y.
They're both called
controlled-NOT operations, and we just need to specify
which one of the bits is the control bit and
which one is the target bit.
This operation has the action
that you see right here on standard basis states and you can check that
action against the definition
of the operation. And here is the matrix
representation of the operation.
When we think about this operation, we have in mind that there
are these two separate bits and they play the roles that I just described with
X being the control bit
and Y being the target bit, but there's really nothing
about this action here or this matrix representation
that demands that we
think about these two bits as being separate bits.
We could alternatively just
think about this operation as being a deterministic
operation on a system having four classical states
that we've decided to name
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 and 1,1.
Here's another example of
a probabilistic operation on two bits, which isn't a deterministic
operation this time.
The operation sets Y to be equal to X with probability one half and otherwise it goes the other way and it sets X to be equal to Y.
This operation doesn't have a special name it's just meant as an example.
And here's the matrix
representation of this operation.
You can see that it can be expressed as an average of two matrices, one that represents the
deterministic operation
where Y is set to whatever
value is stored in X and the other that sets
X to be equal to Y.
So here we see that we can take averages of stochastic matrices to obtain new ones just like we had in the previous lesson.
Now, let's consider
the following question. Suppose that we have two
probabilistic operations each on its own system
described as usual by stochastic
matrices and to be precise, let's suppose that M is
a probabilistic operation
on a system X and N is a
probabilistic operation on a system Y.
The question is if we
simultaneously perform M on X and N on Y, how do we ascribe
the effect that this has
on the compound system XY?
Thinking about about this
intuitively for a moment, if we simultaneously
perform the two operations on their own respective systems,
then we are in fact
performing an operation on the compound system, so it should be described
by some stochastic matrix.
The short answer to this
question is that the matrix is obtained by taking a tensor product, not between vectors like
we talked about earlier,